all choosing the bear
this is because bears are predictable
and will only really be violent if they perceive you as a threat
this is because if you get mauled by a bear
no one is gonna ask you what you are wearing or why you were there
or if you were drunk
I wish I could say the same for men
we call upon our government
our communities our society and every individual to take a stand
and I thank you all for coming here today to do just that
and I thank the men as well who came here today
it's not a popular choice
it's not popular in this country to do that
it should be but it's not
and we need them um to stand with us
we need them to join this movement and this fight
we need everyone to stand up on this issue
and we need preventative measures
not just reactive responses
we demand policies and programmes that educate and reform
that dismantle the structures that enable this violence
Australia is actually
doing some of the most groundbreaking research on men's violence against women
and we are a leader in the world
so we know what to do these people you've all have
you've heard from today they are experts and their organisations know what to do